So the first thing I want you to do is
turn to page 378 this is the beginning of
book nine.
It's a curious feature,
I think of book nine that it,
that that it begins with
a consideration of talk.
The narrator's lamenting the fact that
that Raefiel has just departed the garden
and that soon not ought not long after
Raphael's departure that Adam and eve
will fall and this fall is
going to have an impact.
And this is something that the
the is really emphasizing here.
It's going to have an impact on
the way they talk. For example.
It's going to be impossible after
this point for human beings to enjoy a
friendly conversation with an angel.
So this is how book nine begins.
No more of talk where God
or angel guest with man,
as with his friend,
familiar used to sit
indulgent and within per take,
rural repast permitting him the while
venial discourse on blamed with the,
with the departure now of a of Raefiel
man will never again be permitted to
enjoy venial discourse on blamed.
And venial here has a,
has a special meaning.
It means allowable or permissible.
And Milton suggesting that the,
that the fall brings with
it certain restrictions,
specifically restrictions of language,
and they're start to arise constraints
on speech or what Milton calls here talk.
And when you read the last
two books of paradise lost,
which we'll be doing for the next week,
you'll begin to see just,
just what kinds of restrictions Adam
speech will be subjected to the the Angel
Michael Will,
we'll continually criticized
and correct Adam's talk.
And,
and the general feeling I think of the
last two books can be quite uncomfortable
for,
for just this reason after the fall,
Adam and eve live in a world in which
mere speech itself can be blamed or in
some cases it can be,
it can be prohibited altogether.
The fall is imagined in, uh, in, in books
nine and 10 to have a, as you can, uh,
of course, this is the, this is the event
herald and the heralded in the title.
So it's a big deal. It's imagined to have
a, an enormous range of consequences.
And Milton divides these consequences,
um, into essentially a two categories.
The first,
you have the mythic consequences that
take place are imagined to take place in
the physical world.
And then there are also the psychic,
the psychological consequences that
takes place somewhere within the
consciousnesses of, of Adam
and eve. And it's with,
it's with a great amount of,
of literary,
imaginative literary Gusto that Milton
enumerates the mythic consequences,
which he does at some length. Then in
book 10. So you'll remember that, um,
after the fall, Adam and eve are punished
with bad weather and Milton, it's,
and it's wonderful when Milton
does this kind of thing.
He tries to represent punishment with
as much scientific specificity as he
possibly can.
So the angels are instructed by God to
shift the sun around and to tilt the
poles of the earth, some, some
20 degrees from the sun's access.
And these mythically imagined astronomical
alterations will bring with them the
four seasons, uh, new to
new to earth. And of course,
the inclement wins, the biting cold
that will plague forever and forever.
The sons and daughters of Adam and eve.
Needless to say,
these are enormous changes,
but when you consider the sheer
magnitude of these cosmic shifts,
it's all the more interesting I think.
And all of the more noteworthy that
the effect of the fall that Milton and
laments first in book nine is the effect
on consciousness and the effect on is
specifically on speech.
It's,
it's here in book nine that
Milton signals that his own talk,
his own speech has been
affected by this new subject,
the subject that he has no
choice but to deal with now,
which is that of the fall.
Milton, we'll have to alter,
this is how the argument goes.
He will have to alter the style of his
poem in order to suit the subject matter
of the fall. And so this is, um,
this is what he's doing at line five
or what he tells us he's doing. Um,
I must now change these
notes to tragic and then in,
and the change in Milton's poetic notes,
these musical notes that are of course,
um,
his poetic verses or the,
his is the nature of his
literary literary representation.
The change in these notes
is manifest in a, in a,
in a lot of ways throughout the final
books of paradise lost for, for one thing,
it's here that we have the,
the last invocation of the poem.
Um,
and it's not coincidental.
I think that this last in vocation
in paradise lost is not actually an
invocation at all.
Milton does not directly address the,
um,
Urania the, the, the muse. He could
only speak of her in the third person.
If this is line 20,
if answerable style I can obtain of my
celestial patroness I'm in Milton is
enable, it seems to address the
Muse directly anymore. Um, and how,
how big that if is if answerable
style I can obtain. Um, we,
we, we don't, we don't actually know.
We don't know whether he'll be able
to obtain the answerable style.
There's been a huge, a
falloff in the poets, uh,
poetic self confidence.
He can't express himself on blamed as
he had tried to do in the invocation to
holy light in book three.
You'll remember that question.
May I express the and blamed he's,
he's failed here to clear the
lines of communication, uh,
between himself and, and
this heavenly being. And,
and of course in this, in this
failure, Milton, the narrator,
the persona of the poet
resembles Adam any,
he's no longer permitted this kind of
direct dial access to Urania just as Adam
and eve are no longer permitted.
They're friendly conversations with
a friendly angel like, like Raphael,
they will have conversations with an
angel or Adam will. Um, but Michael's,
as you will see,
Michael's a stern toodle edge.
It can hardly be described as, as
friendly. It's certainly instructive,
but Milton would never be able to bring
himself to use the adjective affable in
characterizing Michael as of course
he did. So charmingly with Raefiel.
So for Milton,
the fault is inextricably connected
to problems of language and,
and specifically no problems of,
of literature.
And so this is what we're going to,
one of the things that
we'll be looking at and,
and this is why I'm not, I'm, I know
I'm always beginning lectures with,
can you believe it,
that we don't find out in paradise lost
until now that this incredibly important
thing happens and I'll be doing it
yet. One more time. It's not until now.
And this seems as a, as, as big a
postponement as any of the postponements.
So that I've mentioned,
it's not until now in book nine that
Milton finally gets around to explaining
why it is he, he decided to write his
epic about the fall, the fall of man.
Look at line 25 since first,
this subject for heroic song pleased
me long choosing and beginning late,
not set jealous by nature to indict wars.
Hither to the only argument,
heroic deemed chief mastery to
dissect with long and tedious havoc,
fabled nights in battles famed and Milton
had intended for for quite some time
as we know to, to write his epic poem
on the subject of a fabled night.
I mean he actually wanted, uh, to,
to have his great English
epic be something like a
continuation of the legend of
King Arthur.
And his epic was going to
be a chivalric romance epic,
like the poems by the great,
the great renaissance
poets Ariosto and Taso,
or of course like the fairy queen by
his own countrymen, Edmund Spenser.
And in fact,
one of the central figures you could say
these central figure in the fairy queen
is just that legendary Arthur that
Milton had as a young man wanted to write
about.
But Milton now insists that it was on
moral grounds that he chose finally chose
not to write his poem in the form of
a heroic Chevelle. Rick Romance. Um,
this is line 32
of book nine.
Milton decided not to devote
or invest his poetic talent in,
in,
in all of those meaningless features of
romance literature that he's now saying
improperly, uh, go into the
title of heroic. So he refuses.
This is line 32 he refuses to describe
races and Games or tilting furniture,
emblazoned shields and praises,
quaint comparisons and steeds
bases and tinsel trappings.
Gorgeous nights at gels and tournament.
And this,
this list is something like a [inaudible].
This is a common,
these are the common elements of the
Romance Trisha tradition and it's kind of
like a,
a cliff notes summary of
all of the conventional
features of a romance like Sir
Phillips, Sydney's Arcadia or
Edmund Spencer's, fairy queen.
And in some cases Milton is actually
lifting entire phrases such as tinsel
trappings, which appears a few
times in the fairy queen. Um,
he's lifting them out of
the pages of Spencer built.
Milton knows perfectly well that this
is a disservice to his favorite poet,
Spencer and the Romances of the very
queen. They're their, their romance.
That is the fairy queen is clearly a lot
more than merely a depiction of battles
and games, although that
certainly is a feature of it.
The most characteristic
feature of the romance genre,
not just in Spencer's hands,
but in the hands of all writers,
all renaissance writers,
their romance,
the most characteristic feature is the
hero or the heroine who travels the
country side in search of adventure,
in search of an opportunity to,
to prove his or her virtue
or an opportunity to prove,
prove his or her courage.
And the principal means by which the
romance plot advances is almost always by
the wandering of its of its heroes.
Heroes and heroines wander
the landscapes of romance,
and there's a lot of ideological
significance attached to
to, to this wandering.
They,
they rarely have set out before them,
some kind of specific map or a guide
that will allow them to proceed along.
They're narrowly defined goal and the
demons and the demons that romance he Rose
Battle and the serpents that they fend
off nearly always come as as this,
this surprise, uh, they're not
discovered with the help of a map.
They're almost always, and this is
certainly the case in the fairy queen,
they're almost always happened upon
the fact that Romancey rose have simply
wandered into an adventure,
only proves their virtue and
their courage all the more. Um,
once of course they have prevailed.
It's important. It's important
that Milton has waited so long to,
to explain his rejection of the genre of
romance as the form that the great his
great poem would take. And
that's because the, the,
the rejection of romance I think has
everything to do as he's imagining it with
the consequence of the fall
in paradise lost. Um, what,
what are the most convincing elements
I think of Satan's temptation of eve is
his attempt to turn her
act of disobedience into
an act of romance chivalry.
So look at the look at
book nine line six 90
Seton suggest to eve at six 92 that that
God won't incense his eye or for such a
petty trespass as eating the
fruit. Um, and then he continues.
God will praise rather you're dauntless
virtue in the world of romance.
Uh,
the,
the idea of obedience isn't nearly as
important as the idea of courage or what
Satan calls here, uh, in,
in perfect chivalric language
dauntless virtue and Sec St.
It was essentially attempting,
he's tempting to,
he's tempting to eve to think of
herself as a heroine of a romance, as,
as if you were saying you're listening,
I don't know what you've heard,
but you're not a character in a biblical
tragedy. You're not a character.
Even in a biblical epic,
you are Wandering Knight in a shovel,
Rick Romance and your only job actually
is to prove your courage to prove your
virtue. And of course, um,
eve is dead wrong to,
uh,
to apply the assumptions of romance to
this decidedly unromantic test of her
obedience. But Milton gives us
for that moment a little glimpse,
this moment of Satan's temptation.
He gives us a little glimpse into a
possible alternative to the story of Eve.
The, the, the, the told in
the book of Genesis, if the,
if the story of Eve had been framed in
the genre of romance rather than in the
genre of tragedy than eve
might've been rewarded.
Rather than punished for
her eating of the fruit,
I'm her courage would have been praised
rather than her disobedience blamed.
So bill Knowlton rejects
the genre of romance.
Of course he has no choice but to as a
viable literary mode in the description
of the fall in book nine.
But he does so only after he's made
ample use and he's exploited it,
uh,
to an extraordinary degree.
And I think he's made ample use of
the principle movement of Romance.
And that's the movement of wandering milk.
This,
this poem is filled with
images of wandering as if,
as if the poem shows traces or some kind
of literary residue of the genre that
Milton decided not to write this
epic poem in the Romance as,
as if somewhere inside of this is,
uh, of this, uh, this biblical epic,
there's a romance, epic's Chevelle,
Rick epic struggling to get out. Uh,
when Milton rejects the romance
genre in this, in vocation,
he begins to alter the poem sense of
the meaning and the poems since of the
significance of the very activity of,
of wandering.
So Adam and eve, and it's incredibly
depressing if you, as most people have,
um, have grown up listening
to your parents argue. Um,
they began about the causes of
the fall and they, they, they,
they lapse into a,
uh,
a depressing cycle of mutual recrimination
and Adam insists that eve fell
because of a tendency she had to wander,
you know,
look what happened. He let her wander
off yesterday morning. And you know, you,
you know the story,
that's essentially his argument and the
subject of eads wandering becomes the
focal point of the first
marital argument after the fall.
So Adam rejects eves wandering just as
Milton as rejecting the whole genre of
wandering, the, the, the, the
literary form of the Romance.
And I think that there's a way in which
these two forms of rejection or are
closely related and what's at stake
with both of these forms of rejection,
these acts of rejection is, is a
problem of language. [inaudible] nope.
So when Milton Rights in line 20 of
the invocation that he's struggling,
he,
he writes that he's struggling to find
an answerable style as style that will
answer to this, this new occasion,
the tragic occasion of the fall.
He needs to change his style in a way
that can actually answer to the tragedy
that he's about to describe. And
so as a literary event, the, the,
the fall makes its biggest
impact I think on the,
through a change in the style of the
poem through the systematic. And,
and by that I mean there's something
like a systematic alteration of,
uh, of the use of certain
key words. So I'm going to,
I'm going to be focusing for a moment
on the changes undergone by a particular
word. Um, and you've probably
already guessed what it
will be a particular word in
paradise lost.
Although there are a number of words
that seem to undergo similar or at least
closely related, uh, changes
over the course of the poem.
But here I'll be looking
at the word wander.
That word wander or wandering or some
version of that word appears no fewer than
32 times in a, in, in paradise lost.
And without question,
I think every appearance of of the
word is loaded. The energy charging,
the word wander comes from the fact I
think that it has embedded within it or
attached to it in some way the entire
genre of the Chevelle rec romance that of
course Milton has rejected and it's almost
as if the word wander is a code word
for romance.
And when Milton uses the word wandering,
it's almost as if he's alluding to this
Spencerian type of poem that he rejected
when he decided to write paradise lost.
It's a reminder of the kind of poem that
this could have been if it hadn't been
a biblical epic.
And,
and you can see a way in which the
word wandering and paradise lost, um,
seems to range somewhere or move perhaps
back and forth between two distinct
meanings. And so I've, I've, um,
it's a little confusing, but I've,
I've given us, uh, something,
a schematic version of the
semantic spectrum that the
word wander in habits in,
in, uh, in paradise lost.
So I guess you could think of the pure
or the innocent meaning of wander is,
is, is purely spatial. It,
it is purely a spatial description of
a kind of directionless or unforced
motion. Um, and then as,
as the further you move to
the right of the spectrum,
you get it's figurative and
therefore its moral meaning,
which is error error.
The pejorative sense of Aaron Aaron out
simply has wandering and straying from
the law, wandering as a divergence
from that which God wants you,
that which God wants you to do.
So from a kind of pure and
uncontaminated meaning, um,
to the right of the spectrum to
something much more morally pejorative,
you can actually think of the word
wander as something like a Chevelle Rick
Knight that undergoes its own set
of adventures and challenges and
transformations over the course
of this poem. So let's, um,
let's look at an early
instance of the word wander.
This is book two line one 46.
This is be legal in the console.
The great debate in in Hell when Billy
Allen book to ponders the possibility of
the annihilation of the angels.
It's a horrible possibility for him.
The consequences that,
uh,
the consequence theater he imagines
as most painful and most absolutely
unbearable is the possibility that his
mind will no longer be able to wander.
So be legal asks this question.
This is line one 46 at book too,
for who would lose though full of pain.
This intellectual being these thoughts
that wander through eternity and sure
Bilio is a fallen angel and nothing goes
out of his way to provide a kind of doc
trinal condemnation of
everything and be Leo speech.
But there's no sense actually that
there's anything wrong with the general
concept of,
of,
of intellectual wandering and in fact be
Lele seems to be quoting Milton himself
from Aereo budgeted can,
which Milton celebrates above all things,
the white to wander,
the right to wander through literature,
through all of one's reading
and all of one's cultural,
cultural exposure without a guide.
Milton rights scenario politica that God
gives us mines and he loves this fact.
God gives us minds that wander
beyond all limit and satiety and,
and the whole principle
of divine wandering. Now,
the whole principle of human wandering
has given a powerful divine sanction, um,
in, in area politica. And so
initially in paradise lost,
we have just that kind
of innocent, uh, innocent
meaning to the word wandering
it as, as it appears. Um,
early in the poem, um, look
at another early instance.
This is book four line two 33.
Page two,
83 of the Hughes.
Um,
Milton's describing here how the four
rivers of paradise spread out and travel
through the earth.
How the river divided into four
main streams runs diverse wandering,
many of famous realm and country.
So the river divides into four streams,
wandering,
many of famous realm and country. Um, and,
and here it's a river that's been
actually cast in the role of, uh,
of the hero of a chivalric romances.
Typically of course it's the night a
Chevelle Rick Knight who wanders many of
famous realm and country.
Now we may be tempted to assume that
because of the rivers of Eden or wandering
through the countryside,
that there's already a tendency toward
something like moral error or straying
from the law of built somehow
into the landscape of the garden.
We may assume that Adam
and eve will naturally,
how could they not stray from the proper
path of obedience if they live in a
natural world that is itself
continually Strang and and wandering.
But Milton invites us
to make that connection,
but then a slaps our wrists for
even entertaining it for a moment.
He uses wandering here in these early
passages in an almost aggressively
innocent sense. He simply wants
to describe a nonlinear emotion,
a direction that hasn't been dictated
or directed by a by a higher power.
And, and one of the, and
I've made this point before,
but one of the labors of reading paradise
lost is knowing when to recover and
then actually trying to recover the purely
innocent significance of some of the
poems.
Keywords.
So the idea of an innocent wandering
is central to Milton's poem because the
activity of wandering and the,
the activity of wandering and the
principle of freewill are so absolutely
intimately connected.
If think about it,
if wandering is a,
is is a motion that doesn't follow a
predetermined or a predestined path,
then then the wanderer is necessarily
always free from the constraints of,
of,
of an external force.
Or You could say that the wander is
always free on some level from the
constraints or the guidance
even have an omnipotent God.
The variability to wander the right to
wander is something like a guarantee or a
strong proof of one's freedom.
In book nine, though, this is,
this is one of the reasons this book
can be so hard to read. Um, the,
the very notion of wandering starts to
come under suspicion and there's a sense
that Milton can't afford any
longer to be so free. Uh,
and his talk about wandering,
no more talk of innocent wandering.
He might've begun. Uh, this book with the,
with the fall wandering is no longer
and blamed or venial to use those words,
uh, from the, from the
opening, quasi in vocation, it,
it comes under a new set
of ethical constraints.
And it's almost as if I'm wandering by
the time you get to book nine no longer
has an opportunity or the liberty to
occupy the innocent or the left hand side
of the semantic spectrum,
but it's almost entirely forced
to occupy the figurative,
the moral and specifically
the morally pejorative, uh,
side of that words meaning.
Um,
so look, let's take a look at
how that, that happens. Um,
this is page three 93 in the Hughes book,
nine line six,
36 34 and Milsons describing Satan's
leading a vive to the tree of knowledge,
obviously a consequential event and eve
as compared to an amazed night wanderer,
I would night wander or who has been
diluted and misled by a wandering fire.
And I'm wondering if fire is a
meteor, uh, moving across the sky.
And at the moment of the fall,
all of those wonderfully liberating
significance is that had been attached to
the notion of wandering suddenly
seem to just drop out of the equation
altogether.
And the evil that we have,
no choice but to associate
with Satan starts to start.
The evil starts to absorb and,
and suck up all of those innocent,
those beautiful associations
that the word wandering had had.
And so instead of, uh, a
capacious semantic spectrum,
you get something like a rigid and much
more fixed sense of the meaning of this
word wandering by the time
we get to the fall. Um,
let's look on this is page
404 in the Hughes a line,
1000, 134 of book nine, 1134.
By the time Adam gets around a blaming
eve for the fall. And of course,
of course he does that, um, uh, uh,
that the word wander has been
entirely confined to the moral,
the morally pejorative part of its
semantic range. And so for Adam,
and he says remarkable. Uh, the,
the point at which he falls isn't what we
know to be the point at which he falls,
which is the moment
that she eats the fruit.
The point at which he
falls according to Adam.
Here is that moment in
which you wandered away.
She wandered away after their argument
or their conversation about their
separation. And so we, it
says to eve at line 11, 34
would vow hat's Tarkin to my words and
stayed with me as I'd be softy when that
strange desire of wandering
this unhappy mourn, I know,
not whence possessed theme,
that's strange desire of wandering.
I think it's, I think it's painful
almost to hear Adam used that phrase,
that strange desire of wandering
as if wandering. We're a concept,
so alien and so foreign,
uh,
in the world of Paradise,
Milton tells us, uh,
just above this passage
at, at, at line 1132,
that Adam is speaking in an altered
style and this alteration of style is,
uh,
surely on the one hand this,
the angry tone of voice that he's
using as he's speaking to his wife.
But it's also,
I think a certain restriction
of semantic possibility.
The possibility of,
of the significances of the
words that he's using and,
and hear the word wandering can only
have it's morally pejorative meaning,
and there's a sense in which Matt in
which Adam is condemning not just eve,
but the whole range of freedoms that lip
that Milton had been working so hard to
establish in as,
as important actually crucial
components of the, uh,
of his liberal universe.
Well,
Eve hears this and she's right.
She's right to be perfectly aghast.
And she's a gas not simply because
Adam is, as he is, is, is, uh,
is exhibiting a kind of surprisingly
unbecoming capacity for rudeness.
It's not just the tone of
voice that appalls her.
She's also appalled by the
altered style of Adam speech,
by which I mean the powerfully reductive,
a force of his tall talk.
Look at line 1144 this is Neve,
what words have passed by lips,
Adam's severe imputes that that
imputes Dow that to my default or,
and you can see the kind of quotation
marks that Eva's putting in the air right
now.
Um,
imputes though that to my default or
we'll have wandering as now cost it.
Eve is eve is right.
I think to be surprised that this altered
this fallen use of the word wandering
has passed Adam's lips. And you can
almost hear her say, listen, you know,
what's going on? I always thought
wandering was a good thing.
A wandering is of course what the
river's in paradise do. Adam and I,
and I thought that the right to wander,
it's a right that we possess as
creatures in a creatures of freewill in,
in a, in a free place. How dare
you blame the fall on wandering
and, and one thing I think we can say
for eve is that she's an excellent,
she's an excellent reader of poetry.
And like a good reader.
She's bristling here at the
suggestion that a word as capacious,
as wandering is capable,
only have one type of significance.
There's a sense that before the fall
words in Milton's poems had a kind of
nimbleness.
There was a,
there was a flexibility to them and
ultimately as you, as you remember,
Milton unimagined,
his verse style is something like the
verbal equivalent of an angel's body.
Um,
his poem was a body of verse that was
free of restrictive joints and limbs of
the traditional rhymed couplet.
And there was a suppleness that that'll
allowed words and phrases and whole
sentences to assume a h a a huge array
of meanings just as angels can either
sexism in,
in heaven.
But there's a sense in which words seem
to lose a lot of their suppleness. Um,
after the fall. And this
depressing, lots of, of,
of a kind of linguistic
mobility is for Milton.
I think one of the central crises of,
of the poem,
a word like wander suddenly begins
to to assume joints and limbs.
It becomes arthritic and, and its meanings
become restricted and reduced to a,
to a black and white world of
good and bad. Uh, and, and, and,
and it's not,
it's not just wander.
There are other keywords that
undergo similar transformations. Um,
slightly different
transformations of course,
because they are different
persons are different characters,
but I'm thinking of words such
as fruit or error or taste.
Any of these would make
an excellent paper topic,
a tracing of the history of the word
as it progresses through the poem.
So words that had been so polyvalent,
so,
so multifaceted are, are beginning
suddenly to be concretized as,
as moral error.
The words are becoming polarized.
They're pushed to the opposite
poles of good and evil. And,
and this moved to reductive
signification has seem to have, I think,
and Milton wants us to see it as having
some disastrous consequences for his
poem.
And one of the most disastrous
consequences of the new
altered style of paradise
lost involves the poems,
new understanding of e four for a while,
for a while it seemed possible that the
official line on sexual hierarchy was
just one was just one of of of the
possible readings of of Paradise.
They'll government.
There were at least some suggestions.
I thought they were at least
some suggestions that that
that there was actually
a kind of natural equality between Adam
and eve and that the matter of hierarchy
was like a cultural imposition of an
arbitrary order onto the naturally
egalitarian status of their relationship.
A cultural imposition that
God himself had imposed,
at least as you know very well at least
I have found myself over the last couple
of weeks trying to make a case for
a certain openendedness to the,
to human relations,
to the relations between the sexes in
Milton's Eden and I'm willing now to
confess,
I will confess here and now that maybe
I pushed that case a little too far.
I pushed that case of this openendedness
to the relation between Adam and eve a
little further than the
poem would actually allow me
to push it. And if I have,
um, if I have had, uh,
gone too far in that particular
interpretive direction
over the course of these
last, let's say three or four lectures,
the poem now is correcting me,
my wrist is being slapped, and by the
time we get to the end of book nine,
it's becomes impossible. And it becomes
even possibly impossible for me.
And I can push this stuff pretty hard to
maintain the case for the gray areas or
the blurred edges that
surround the, the, the poems,
the poem sexism. So, so no more of talk.
No more of Rogers's talk of
Milton's infinitely feel good,
flexible feminism. Um, your, your,
your professor can now be seen to
have strayed beyond the bounds of,
of responsible, responsible pedagogy. And
perhaps you'd be, you'd be well advised.
I Dunno,
it's up to you whether you should just
throw away your notes from the last, um,
three or four lectures or I will advise
Dan the cameraman simply to erase.
We'll erase the last three tapes.
Um,
because maybe I was entirely
wrong after the fall,
there's less and less of an alternative
to Raefiel his insistence on,
on sexual hierarchy. Everything
is much more black and white now.
And any ambivalence that that may have
been expressed about the justice of Eve's
subjection to Adam seem simply in some
way to just disappear after the fall.
One of the divine punishments,
and it's always started strikes
students has kind of odd that one of the
punishments that follows the fall is the
official subjection of women to man the
sun. The Sun and Paradise lost passes
judgment on eve and he declares it.
This is in book 10 to thy
husbands will vine shall submit.
He over thee shall rule. And a lot,
you know, often we ask, well, what's,
what's the big deal? How is this
different from their situation before?
But it is the big deal and
this is a punishment. Um,
you'll remember that eve before the fall
had always been in a position to choose
to yield, to add them. Um,
and here she, she no longer has
a choice. She just gets seized.
And she's never given
the opportunity to yield.
And maybe the distinction strikes some
of us as as, as a little specious,
but it's a,
it's a meaningful one I think to Milton,
but there's more to the fall than just
this official de la laying down of a new
law,
a newly rigorous and newly and
forest law of sexual subordination,
of involuntary, involuntary
sexual, uh, subjection.
Look at page four 27 in the Hughes.
This is book 10 line eight 67.
There's, there's a, there's
a new subjection of language,
the subjection of language
to a new altered style. Um,
and in this passage we have Adam really
at his most misogynist eve comes to Adam
and try to make amends after the fall.
And Adam just lets loose with this
powerful antifeminist invective.
So this is line eight 67 of book 10 out
of my sight vow serpent that named best
befits the with him lead thy
self is false and hateful.
Nothing wants but that they
shaped like his and colors.
Serpent teen may show the inward fraud
to warn all creatures from the henceforth
and the fall brings with it a
new name for eve serpent and,
and is actually thinking of one of the
incredibly mean spirited and I think it
was actually mistaken, but it was a
traditional etymology for the name Eve,
which had at various
points over uh, the, the,
the history of biblical interpretation
actually in the Hebrew was believed to
have meant serpent.
Adam here identifies eve with the serpent
and he's providing a significance for
eve the word eat,
that that drastically constricts
the enormous range of meanings that,
that we may have associated with
her up to this point that we,
we were right presumably do
associate with her up to this point.
You'll remember that in
book for the weaving,
motions of Eve's hair had been juxtaposed
implicitly with the waving winding
motions of the serpent.
And one of the points of
that juxtaposition was to
come to understand that the,
the waving wandering motion was
entirely innocent before the fall.
That only comes to be associated
with with moral error.
I'm the right hand side of the semantic
spectrum after the fall. But, but,
but once again,
um,
Adam reveals to suddenly reveals himself
to be an abominable reader of poetry
and uh,
and absolutely incapable of nuance and
suggestiveness and he reinterpreted,
he reinterprets all of the
innocent similarities between
the wandering waviness
of eve and the serpent into something
like an absolute identification with evil.
The neem eve suddenly takes on the force
of something like a morally pejorative
word,
and Adam only makes his case stronger
by reiterating this new black and white
understanding of the concept of
wandering. Get this, um, this is,
um, line eight 73 of book 10, but for the,
he tells eve, but for the,
I had persisted happy,
had not die pride and wandering
vanity when least was safe.
Rejected my fore warning
pride in wandering vanity wandering as
practically taken on the force of a, uh,
of a curse word.
In this sentence,
it's lodged contemptuously between
pride and vanity. As if out of nowhere,
Milton is elevating the notion
of wandering to something
like the eighth deadly
sin. Uh, the, the, the very, the
very idea of wandering. Of course,
we know this insists upon the importance
of, of ambiguity and ambivalence.
And I think it's just this ambiguity and
Ambo ambivalence that Adam has really
lashing,
lashing out out.
He's struggling to align the concept of
wandering with some of the most hateful
and some of the most misogynist
impulses of the poem. It's,
it's, it's important though to,
to understand that it's not just,
and it's depressing also to understand
that it's not just Adam who's responsible
for the reduction of eve and the reduction
of Eve's wandering to the status of
moral error.
That the poem itself seems to be
lending a kind of disconcerting, um,
authority to this
misinterpretation of eve.
I think it's a misinterpretation
of eve when Adam Falls, the, the,
the text makes clear that it's for very
different reasons from Eve's fall even
fallen out of deception.
And Adam had fallen out of love.
He knew precisely what he
was doing. Uh, this is,
this is what the narrator
tells us at line. Uh,
and you don't need to turn their
line nine 97 to book at book nine.
Adam scruple not to eat against
his better knowledge, not deceived,
but fondly overcome with female charm,
fondly overcome with female term,
fondly overcome with female charm.
What sense does that make? That that's,
that's the narrators in interpolation.
The narrator is giving an a new
authoritative interpretation
of the event of the
fall. And I think it's an entirely
unfair, and it's not just unfair.
This is wrong.
Adam falls,
we know this because of his
sense of his marital bond.
I think he's wrong to fall actually.
Um, but it's not that he was, uh,
overcome with thieves.
Uh, female charm. He says,
our state cannot be severed.
We are one,
one flesh to lose the word to lose myself.
And he falls.
He falls out of this,
his sense of connectedness with the,
but he doesn't fall because he's been
seduced by his wife that the narrator has
interpreted Adam's fallen away.
That I think the text
itself simply can't support.
And it's a central example of
how reductive interpretations
aren't just to be
attributed to Adam,
but they're beginning actually
to insinuate themselves
into the authoritative
voice of the, of the narrator book.
10 of paradise lost is,
is the book given to the representation
of the consequences of the fall?
And given that one of the effects of
the fall is, as I've been describing,
is something like the imaginative
shrinkage that language suffers. We,
we shouldn't really be at all surprised
by one of the early and very strange
actions and book 10 it's,
it's here that we,
that we witness that
we're forced witness the,
the reappearance of the debased.
And what I think is for this poem the
entirely inappropriate genre of allegory.
Suddenly as if from,
as if from nowhere a Milton re-inject
into his otherwise realistic poem,
the decidedly unreal figures
of, of, of sin and death.
So look at book 10 line to 29 this is
page four 11 and the Hughes a Milton
describes the sun's descend to Earth
to pass judgment on Adam and eve.
And at line two 29,
he gives us a description of a set
of events that's been happening
simultaneously.
And he uses this meanwhile structure
a few times in paradise lost. Uh,
meanwhile air thus was sinned and judged
on earth within the gates of hell.
Set Sin and death and, and the, and,
and with this use of the meanwhile
structure of the narrative, um,
Milton's allow,
allowing us to see the activity of sin
and death not happening at a later point
in the story of the fall. It's happening
at the same time as the fallen. In fact,
it's the same event.
It's simply at the same event,
told from a different perspective, a
different point of view. And of course,
it's told within an, within an
entirely different literary mode.
And one of the consequences of the fall
has been a certain reduction of meaning,
as I've been describing, undergone
by some of the poems, uh,
keywords.
And here in book 10,
Milton Constructs an entire
scene out of that literary mode,
traditionally most given to reductive
meanings. And that's the, the,
the mode of allegory.
It's,
it's an allegory that when
performed hamfisted Lee,
um,
you have a one to one correspondence
between an image and it's meaning there
isn't that, there isn't traditionally an
allegorical writing the same kind of a
proliferation of meanings that you
can have in other literary modes.
The follows the moment of course at
which Adam and eve sin and the moment at
which they are consigned to suffer
the penalty of death. You know,
that much we accept and is
perfectly reasonable. Um,
but,
but here after the fall,
Milton chooses to represent this new
introduction of sin and death within the
motive allegory.
And the result has to be
one of the most bathetic,
one of the most preposterous scenes
in all of paradise lost. It's a,
it's a, it's an embarrassment. Um,
turn to page the top of page
413 in the Hughes line to 82.
This is the argument since there
will presumably be after the fall,
a greater deal of communication between
Earth and hell. The allegorical monsters,
sin and death find
themselves in the position of
constructing and actual bridge,
uh,
constructing an actual,
a bridge that will connect the earth
with the home of the fallen angels,
the hell.
And so Milton represents the building
of this bridge as some massive public
works project.
And there's,
and I think there's every indication
here that he's intending this
representation to strike us
as, as as perfectly absurd, um,
sin and death begin to build the bridge.
This is the line to 82 then both from out
hell gates into the waste wide anarchy
of chaos. Damp and dark,
flew diverse and with power,
their power was great
hovering upon the waters.
And you'll notice here
that we have a parody of,
of God's creation where the Holy Spirit
had hovered upon the waters of chaos and
made it pregnant. Um, I'll
continue what they met.
Solid or slimy as enraging see
tossed up and down together,
crowded,
drove from each side,
show Ling toward the mouth of hell as
when to polar winds blowing adverse.
And I'm skipping around here together.
Drive mountains of ice.
It's a,
it's a,
it's a brilliant but a grotesque travesty
parody of Gods vitalist creation of
the universe,
the process whereby impregnated matter
or begins organically to organize itself
into the, into the, into
the beautiful creation,
synonyms in death with their
ham fisted creators here,
they can't impregnate, caused
chaos of course. So they,
they build a bridge over chaos by,
by manhandling,
by manhandling chaos.
They forced together all of the solid
and all of the slimy stuff into one huge
pile. It's a, it's a grotesque image,
but it's grotesquery I think
serves an important point. I mean,
it serves as Milton's emblem for,
among other things,
his emblem for the process undergone
by language after the fall. It's,
it's as if he's representing the shoulding
together into one concrete block.
All of the diverse and all of the various
meanings associated with some of the
poems, most resonant, most
beautiful and most suggestive words.
Look at looking at how death gets,
um,
all of the slippery stuff of chaos. You
know, it's, it's wonderfully slippery,
um, to hold together in the
form of a bridge line two 93,
the aggregated soil death with his
mace [inaudible] cold and dry as with a
trident smoked and
fixed as firm as de Los,
the floating island as
deloads floating ones.
The rest his look bound with
Gorgonian rigor not to move.
And with asphaltic slime death has
the ability to fix this preposterous
allegorical,
allegorical character death
has the ability to fix
something fluid and flexible
into something from and asphaltic and,
and,
and I think you have one of the most,
one of the most powerful images of
the aesthetic disaster that is fallen
language. The extraordinary matter of, of,
of chaos is being concretized concretized
here it's subjected to a pro process.
Exactly like the linguistic conquered
association undergone by a word like
wander or the words fruit or error.
These words begin to succumb to a
kind of link linguistic rigor mortis.
They ossify into a moral rigidity that
I think would have seemed perfectly
unthinkable to us at an, at
an earlier stage in, in the,
in the poem.
I,
okay. I, I have, um, I've,
I have another second. Um,
we have what we have time.
I think for one more example,
this is the punishment of Satan.
When God,
when God punishes Satan for tempting eve,
he does so in a way that makes literal
and actual Satan's association with the
serpent. Um, and it's really quite vulgar.
Satan had of course just temporarily
inhabited the body of the serpent and God
punished is Satan by turning
this temporary association
into something like an
actual condition.
Look at book 10 live and five 55.
This is page four, 19. Uh, Satan is
metamorphosed. You'll remember in day two,
a huge and hideous serpent at the
gigantic public assembly in Hell. And,
but Milton doesn't stop at that vulgar,
quasi allegorical representation
after Satan has met.
After that Milton metamorphoses,
all of the fallen angels into serpents
and he and he places before them a grove
of trees, all of them c
containing the forbidden fruit.
So the fallen angels who are announced
serpents are all so thirsty and so hungry
that they can't help but climb the
trees and try to taste the fruit.
This is line five 55, yet parched
with scolding thirst and hunger,
fierce vote to dilute them
sent could not abstain,
but on they rolled in heaps and up the
trees climbing set thicker than this
snaky locks that curled McGarrah.
Mcgarrah was one of the,
one of the furies,
the feminine figures in classical
mythology who punish sin.
And like Medusa Mcgarrah has
serpents for locks of hair.
And I think it's impossible to
read these lines and not, uh,
not see in them an embedded an incredibly
unfair and ugly but embedded image of
eve.
The beautiful waving,
wandering tresses of Eve have been
identified now categorically and
unrepentantly with the serpent,
the serpent who was her downfall.
And the poem seems to go about as far as
it can go in the absolute ossification
of a character into a kind of empty
embodiment of, of, of, of moral evil.
The actual image of metamorphose
metamorphoses here is, uh, is,
is merely a narrative version of a process
that we've seen occur in the language
of paradise lost for,
for some time now,
moral ambivalence and poetic ambiguity
has been transmogrified into something
like moral definitiveness.
And literary ambivalence
has become a literary,
literal mindedness.
Well,
happily the poem isn't over yet.
And,
and the grotesque reduction
of Eve to evil is by no means,
uh, the poems, last words.
So think about as you read books 11
and 12 for next time, think about the,
the literary texture of those books as
you compare it to the earlier books.
Um, uh, the poem it has
off. It used to be argued,
and it's an incredibly stupid argument
that Milton was simply getting old and
tired by the time he got around
to writing books 11 and 12. Um,
but of course he rent Wah, he went on
to write statements and Samson agonists,
Deason and paradise regained
magnificent works of art.
But there is nonetheless a marked change
in the verbal character of the last two
books of paradise lost through.
So think about the implications
of the altered style of,
of the book's conclusion.
Okay.